the United Kingdom home of fascinating
wildlife like The Fearless mating foxes
of Kent and beautiful mountains that go
largely unexplored by the carefree
mating foxes of Kent it's also home to
some of the world's most gifted artists
like whomever took this picture of the
stoic mating foxes have Kent
unfortunately the UK is about to be
completely in a way not unlike
the resigned mating foxes of Kent the UK
had some very big news the UK has a new
prime minister Boris Johnson took over
today from Theresa May sealing the
transition of power in a handshake with
a queen he bowed then broke the rules by
telling his new staff what she said
exactly and it was apparently and I
quote Deez Nuts
so true she said it to every prime
minister since Winston Churchill and she
won't say why but yes
incredibly Britain's new prime minister
is Boris Johnson and even if you know
nothing about British politics you're
probably already vaguely aware of him as
mayor of London he famously got stuck on
a zip line while promoting the 2012
Olympics and if you've ever seen a photo
of him you will probably remember it
because it's honestly hard to find one
where he doesn't look ridiculous in fact
everything about his appearance is
consistently immaculately wrong here is
wearing a bike helmet but somehow both
too small and too big for his head
that's not easy to do here is looking
like what would happen if an egg could
be both hairy and sad even his childhood
pictures are funny because here he is
looking more like a young and a winter
than I'm guessing she did at that age
you might even have seen this clip that
went viral recently of Boris's
endearingly weird answer to a very
simple question about what he does to
relax I have a thing where I make models
of Bieber lies in love where Marilyn
that we build a beautiful I make busses
you make models a bus I make models of
fast see they're going down sister so so
what I do know what I do mean models
about what I make is I get I get
old I don't like wooden crates yeah
right and then I paint them making cold
oscillate that's what you do to enjoy
yourself hey no I paint the passengers
enjoying themself okay
great wonderful bus okay so so three
things about that one yes it's
magnificent - there's just no way that's
true but three if it were true
I now want nothing more than to see one
of those buses because if
they're terrible that's weird but if
they're impressive that's somehow
weirder the very idea of the new Prime
Minister painting crates buses in his
spare time to relax is just endlessly
fascinating but Boris is so much more
than the potential Michelangelo of
vehicular crafts he was an absolutely
crucial leader in the brexit campaign
famously riding around in a gigantic red
non crate bus with a complete lie
splashed across the side of it and now
he is Prime Minister and has to face the
challenge of finalizing a brexit
withdraw deal by October 31st which is
less than 100 days from now and the
consequences of messing that up could
have catastrophic ramifications for
Britain Europe and the world so tonight
we thought it might be helpful to
explain who exactly Boris Johnson is and
let's start with the fact that given
that Britain's new leader is a clownish
vicar with silly hair and a passing
relationship with the truth you may
already be thinking of the person you're
almost always thinking about anyway and
you are not alone in that there've been
countless headlines comparing Boris to
Donald Trump and just this week Trump
did it himself they're saying Britain
Trump they can't print trap and people
are saying that's a good thing
that they like me over there no they
don't they don't they absolutely do not
they they don't like you over there and
no one ever says Britain Trump unless
it's in the context of a sentence like
I'm getting the out of Britain
Trump is coming to visit this weekend
but two colorful brittle truck is
neither exactly wrong no exactly right
Johnson is actually a lot more complex
than Trump in a number of important ways
for one while Trump tells you he has the
best words but doesn't Johnson is more
than happy to show you how erudite he is
just watch him charmingly drop some
sporting trivia ahead of the London
Olympics ping-pong was invented on the
dining tables of England it was and it
was called with Wow I think you have
central difference between us and the
rest of the world other nations the
French looked at a dining table and saw
an opportunity gab dinner we looked at
the dining table and sort of duty to
play with what I wanted mix that is
objectively funny although I'm not sure
that that with woth anecdote reflects
quite as well on the British as he's
implying there
the French looked at the dining table as
a canvas upon which to create
exceptional cuisine and the British saw
a way to basically invent Moss tennis
and look Johnson is more than happy to
look ridiculous it enabled him to not
just survive when he up but
actually benefit that observes zipline
photo from the Olympics would have
killed most politicians careers the
Boris found a way to laugh at himself
and charm everyone just watch how it got
covered on the news at the time isn't
that fantastic
this is a man whose summer tipping as a
future prime minister
look I think if anyone has won the
Olympics I would say it's Boris Johnson
oh hold on man
if anyone want me Olympics to be clear
people definitely won the Olympics
specifically the winners the winners won
the Olympics and in a nutshell that has
been the root of Boris's appeal a
lovable mess weathering adversity with
humor and good cheer but the truth is
there may be a great deal more
calculation behind that image than first
appears because Boris learned at an
early age the benefit of making yourself
the butt of the joke as his own sister
remembers he discovered he could make
people laugh when he was in a French
play and he had to recite mallya and he
hadn't bothered to learn his lines and
he hid behind a pillar reading them out
which will obviously much funnier than
if he'd learned them perfectly and it
stood on a stage and acclaimed them yeah
obviously it's always funnier when
things go wrong like in this photo of
Johnson shaking hands with the Queen Oh
Oh what an embarrassing mistake see
objectively folia and by the way how are
neither of you into this
Boris Boris actually learned a great
deal from that incident as he himself
will admit do you think they do you
learned something for later life from
acting in plays at Eton that you could
actually get more laughs by looking as
if you don't know your lines then
actually remembering them well I
certainly think that as a general tactic
in life if that's what you're driving at
it is it is often useful to give the
slight impression that you are
deliberately pretending not to know what
is going on because the reality may be
that you don't know what is going on but
people won't be able to tell the
difference and that right there is the
key to Boris Johnson presenting his own
lack of preparation so charmingly that
you actually doubt he's unprepared but
he is it's an incredibly powerful trick
and incidentally it's clips like that
that a one major reason why Boris is not
the Brittain Trump because can you
imagine Trump having that level of
self-reflection look with with CAF FA
the tactic was to present myself as a
kind of sub literate clown to distract
you from the fact that I'm a mound of
skin totally stretched across the
howling chasm of the space where a soul
should be that's it's a very useful tool
when deployed well the point here is
though Johnson's bumbling persona is a
carefully calibrated act take his hair
multiple people have said he actually
messes it up on purpose a BBC producer
tweeted that he'd always ruffle it right
before the camera started rolling which
kind of makes sense doesn't it he's been
on TV hundreds of times and he always
looks like a mess what were the chances
that before every one of those
appearances he combed gelled and
carefully parted his hair only to then
be hit in the face by a goose
right as they started filming no he
looks like that because he wants to or
take his clothing he's often seen
outside in eccentric chaotic outfits but
he knows how to dress
he just also knows that that is a more
relatable image than this one from when
he was in the notoriously elite
Bullingdon Club at Oxford University
with his friends David Cameron now that
photo was a huge liability for Cameron
but not for Johnson because he's
cleverly inoculated himself against that
image of astonishing privilege by
presenting himself as a cartoon
Englishman who dresses like a raccoon
who just emerged from David Foster
Wallace's trash and once you realise
what he's doing it makes you question
everything that you previously found
charming about him remember that clip
were is talking about painting buses
undeniably funny but some in Britain
have pointed out that it might have been
an attempt to change the Google search
results people receive when they look
for something like Boris Johnson bus
meaning that people would see that
delightful clip rather than this
significantly less delightful
now was that actually his intention it's
impossible to know but you can't rule it
out either
and once you see the possibility that
his gaps are in fact calculated
manipulations you can't unsee it it's
like looking at the FedEx logo and
finally noticing the arrow or or looking
at the Starbucks logo and finally
noticing Robert De Niro's face we can
never look at it in quite the same way
again and beneath all abhorrest his
surface charm are some truly nasty
elements for one thing he is a liar as a
young journalist he was fired from his
first job at the Times of London for
completely making up a quote in fact his
editor claimed Johnson was the single
worst employee he's ever had and skipped
many work dates to hang out with his
best friend Jeffrey Epstein which is
terrible it's not true I just made that
quota
but now you can see just how
irresponsible it is to fabricate them
and from there Johnson failed upwards to
a job at the Daily Telegraph where he
built a following on a series of
flagrant falsehoods about the European
Union as their Brussels correspondent
falsehoods that would help lay the
groundwork for the brexit vote decades
later Johnson even admits they had
something called a save get it's a key
command like a copy/paste
of a phrase that he'd like to use to
paint a caricature of the EU I had a
sort of save get we didn't have saved
get keys a save get kind of intro which
was Britain stood alone last night as
and then I would fill in whatever it was
as Europe proceeded with plans to
abolish the porn cocktail flavor crisp
or whatever so first for those
unfamiliar prawn cocktail crisps are
real they shouldn't be but they are and
to explain how it happened it's what
happens when a country looks at the
dining table and for gos foods in favor
of playing with one Johnson Johnson
actually write a series of columns
claiming Europe was attempting to ban
the prawn cocktail crisps which was a
complete lie
Europe was never planning to abolish
them and they immediately pointed that
out but Boris's allegation spread like
wildfire and became a popular example of
an out-of-control EU and as recently as
2016 a full 25 years after his
was completely debunked Boris actually
cited the great wall against the British
prawn cocktail crisps as part of his
case for brexit and by the way if there
ever is a great war against the prawn
cocktail crispy
there will be no winners believe me
because I will say this it's like eating
a permeated mermaid but but in a bad way
oh that's bad it would be bad enough if
Boris were just a liar but he's also
been more than willing to tap into
outright bigotry to get ahead he's made
repeated references to some immigrants
as people that want to leech off the
state and over the years he's made
references to pickaninnies he said the
people of Congo had watermelon smiles
he's called gay men tank chopped bum
boys and just last year there was this
they look like letterboxes Boris Johnson
wrote on Monday he even compared women
who wear them to bank robbers that is an
appalling comment that leaves a truly
disgusting taste in your mouth
much like the shrimp crisp dust that has
very much voted to remain on my
tongue
and look when reporters camped outside
Johnson's house he really turned the
cartoon version of himself up to 11
ruffling up his hair
donning an absurd outfit and waddling
out to charm them and just watch how
depressingly effective it winds up
solely on a humanitarian mission because
you've been here all day and you've been
incredibly patient and incredibly and I
feel very sorry for you because I had
nothing to say about this about it no
don't take the tea and do not thank him
for it because think about what just
happened there he referred to Muslim
women as letterboxes and in the space of
30 seconds he had them laughing along
with him he was in trouble he put on
full Brett face and those journalists
fell for it and for the record I
can say Brit face you can't I can
definitely say it we can say it together
you can't say it at all that's the rule
but but unfortunately Boris the Prime
Minister may have just hit the limits of
where that charm can take him because
crucially he now has less than a hundred
days to negotiate a brexit deal and his
well-engineered
clumsy Brits persona does not
necessarily travel well we saw that
during his time as foreign secretary in
2017 he was in Myanmar where for some
reason he kept muttering Rudyard
Kipling's colonialist poem Mandalay to
himself come you back register
what this
[Music]
the Ambassador is quick to spot that
reminding their hosts of British rule
might not be wise
[Music]
is it good stuff or is that actually bad
stuff because I would argue as a foreign
secretary it's best not to remind people
of when your country subjugated theirs
for more than a century it honestly
would have been more diplomatic at that
point for him to recite the lyrics to my
neck my back parentheses lick it by kya
my neck my back lick my and my
crack good stuff good stuff John says
time in the Foreign Office was littered
with gas as this journalist explained
with the help of a visual aid
I've spoken to one figure who said that
working with Boris Johnson is like
walking a few feet behind a horse
shovelling its is a striking quote
well I'm not really sure why that
journalist felt the need to be next to a
horse to deliver how did he pitch that
to this fable owner look I'm just
worried that people have forgotten what
horses look like so please stand aside
while I humiliate your animal on the
news and the problem is if Johnson
messes up the brexit negotiation the
pile up of could be considerable
here as most economists believe a No
Deal brexit would cause a deep recession
and the EU may be extra immune to Boris
his charms remember he was a key figure
in the brexit campaign and has lied
about them for decades in his newspaper
columns on top of which he is privately
referred to the French as turds and
publicly compared the EU to Hitler so
he's not working with a lot of goodwill
at this point and Boris has made
extravagant uncapable promises including
that he will somehow devise a way to
sever Northern Ireland from the EU
without creating a hard border with
Ireland but his ejections cannot work
and EU commissioner jean-claude Juncker
has responded pretty clearly to them
young Curie iterated that the e u--'s
position that the withdrawal agreement
is the best and only agreement possible
in other words Yoker said no to Johnson
yeah of course he did so Johnson is
out of luck at this point he's bumbling
charm may
wonders in low stakes situations but
that's not where he is now thinking
think of it like this Hugh Grant is
delightful in romantic comedies the
stammering the hesitation the inability
to relate to his immediate surroundings
with any level of competence you want to
see Hugh Grant in Four Weddings and a
funeral but no one wants to see him in
United 93 because the context would make
his character a lot less charming sorry
I just um well this is a really stupid
question but particularly in view of
your recent is your heart but but I just
wondered if by any chance in the words
of David Cassidy when he was a still
with the Partridge Family I believe you
might be persuaded to shushu dollar will
it obviously this play believe you say
because situation that matters because
Johnson cannot get what he wants or has
promised here and his only hope of
avoiding complete catastrophe is through
focus discipline and detail but those
are three Achilles heels of his I'll
show you one of his great plans for
mitigating the potentially catastrophic
effects of a No Deal brexit is to
suggest that if the UK misses that
October deadline it could simply trade
freely with the EU under article 24
paragraph 5 B of this existing trade
agreement but and you do not need to
know the details of this the very next
paragraph 5c makes it clear that that is
simply not possible and just watch as a
journalist who actually understood that
challenge Johnson on it you talk about
article 5 B article 24 detail right
Andrew how article 24 paragraph 5 and
how would you handle paragraph 5 C I
would was I would confide entirely in
paragraph 5 B because that is how would
you get round what's in 5 C I would
confide entirely in paragraph 5 B which
is do you know what purposes no oh
that--no was delivered with the
confidence of a man who doesn't know
what he's talking about but thinks it
doesn't matter it's a no that says yeah
I'm full of so what just walk a few
feet behind me and clean it up with a
shovel but but that lack of attention to
detail for a process that has the
potential to impact millions of people
is really alarming and there is no
reason for much hope here because all of
the skills that helped Johnson to become
Prime Minister will not paper over all
of the deficits that are going to make
him terrible at that job Johnson has now
backed himself into a corner because
Parliament has rejected the --use deal
the EU says there is no better deal to
be had there is really no good way out
of this meaning that he's pretty much
now stranded and not not the charming
kind of strategy that means you've
somehow won the Olympics because this
time that zipline isn't over Olympic
spectators it's over a volcano it's set
to erupt in three months time and the
only people who can help get him down
are the same people he's accused of
being turds and Hitler's and
unfortunately for Johnson Britain Europe
and the world I just don't think he's
going to be able to with laughs
his way out of this one
you